so you know that shot with the strap
around the hand you know that
controversial shot that we just can't
seem to get over today we're getting to
the bottom of it and we're going
straight to the source Eric sandens here
from what it affects who was the visual
effects supervisor on avatar the way of
water and you brought with you some
exclusive breakdown of the actual shot
thanks the native for sponsoring this
video hey everyone Jordan here and I am
super excited because today we have a
very special very long awaited react
episode but before we get into that I'm
going to tell you about today's sponsor
natives let's just cut to the chase
native is my favorite deodorant it's
aluminum free it's cruelty free and they
keep my pitch dry all day and I mean all
day I put it on in the morning I go to
work all day then I will go hit a Muay
Thai class after work and it's all good
because it has a 72 hour odor protection
it's all good it's all good but that's
not all for one my favorite is the
texture when you put it on it's not
sticky and it feels dry while applying
it smells amazing so this one right here
that I have in my hand is cucumber mint
but at home I have the coconut and
vanilla it smells so good so normally
three deodorants would cost you 39 but
right now if you use our link and put in
the code quarter crew you can get three
deodorants for twenty six dollars that's
33 off but wait there's more if you use
that same code you'll also get 20 off of
all body washes and lotions easy simple
just like your deodorant should be all
right well that's all for me enjoy react
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are here with Eric Sanden Eric is
working at weda these days and was the
visual effects supervisor on Avatar 2
the way of water Eric thanks so much for
being here hey no worries it's fun
coming over and uh sitting with you guys
what kind of films have you worked on uh
mostly little ones uh Lord of the Rings
the original Avatar King Kong Hobbit
movies he's worked on every Lord of the
Rings film every Hobbit film every
Avatar film and sprinkle and a half
dozen other films that are all big
hitters too so in a film like Avatar 2
comes out where there is industry
shifting technology being used yeah that
stuff doesn't happen very often and it's
just an absolute pleasure to be able to
talk to one of the visual Tech
supervisors from the movie to learn more
about the technology for you to share
all that with us today he's going to
answer some questions that the internet
has spent the entire last year wondering
about and I think we are finally gonna
put a nail in the coffin for the shot
that we've all been discussing perhaps
incorrectly for while now there's a shot
in the trailer where Jake is wrapping a
strap around his hand and we're all just
like whoa because the water Fidelity in
that shot was just on like anything we'd
ever seen this is the wettest water I've
ever seen everything you're seeing was
generated by a computer I doubled down
like three times I'm like no this shot
is a hundred percent CG because I have
like a bit biblical faith in the
abilities of what it affects I was like
oh yeah no that's not only possible it's
easy for them and I said that just like
out of Blind Faith but then it started
coming out like oh wait no it's actually
a little bit more complicated than that
and that started an entire debate and so
I think it's time for us to settle that
debate let's settle this debate perhaps
you should start with a new look to
settle the debate we were on stage and
Jim said I can shoot with an actor for
an hour on set and I get the action I
want and we can get the water or I can
[__] around with you guys for three
months trying to get the motion try to
get the water trying to get everything
right so he wanted to actually shoot it
which we did in a kiddie pool a little
plastic one how deep was this pool was
it like literally a foot deep
and we had a little Buck for the ilu or
the skim Wing in this case but what we
did was we shot Kevin Dorman which is
one of the actors that did the most on
this entire film we painted his hand
and we did the strap and the part we
kept was about here down okay the strap
around his hand and a little bit of the
water in between his fingers everything
else is CG oh wow interesting so not
only are you here to tell us the real
story you brought with you some
exclusive breakdown of the actual shot
yeah I haven't watched this yet so we
have not watched this yet
oh there it is
wow that's so intense
it's a lot to take in over uh 100 frames
isn't it it's so much work it's so
intense yeah so that's how you usually
see Kevin is in blue tights
one of the arguments I made was
subsurface scattering effects and paint
just doesn't quite look like real skin
wood and that was my argument against it
being paint on skin unless you paint in
the subsurface feel to it so the thing
we did was we rendered it out and we got
it to look the way we wanted it with the
CG arms and we gave it to the head of
the makeup Sarah rabano so she actually
painted in the subsurface look for the
lighting for that shot so that she got
the proper color the proper Reds all
that stuff so if you come off angle it's
not going to work as well yeah I was
about to say that's only for a very
specific
work we knew what the angle was
[Music]
so crazy wow okay that actually just
blew my mind more than anything it's
always a mix it's like you can have a CG
element but if you have some practical
elements you always want to use as much
of that as possible my I guess my point
of view was that you guys already have
developed some of the most incredible
water simulation techniques and tool
sets and of course you already have
digital copies of all the characters all
of the little items and accessories the
strap why shoot anything practically at
all when you can already achieve that
level of fidelity digitally performance
it's it's just performance right like
because Jim wanted that performance that
he could direct Kevin to do to get the
straps tightening around he wanted that
so uh that's really what it comes down
to especially with Jim because he
doesn't doubt that we can do whatever we
want and whatever he wants us to do
um but it's it's more about his time
right like how much time is it going to
take him to direct that action but yeah
the majority of it is it's really a
combination for both so everyone was
right in a certain way interesting now
it's worth noting that the shot that
we're looking at here is different than
the shot that was in the teaser yeah
that's the one with the blood so in the
original edit he actually went back to
that hand and you saw the blood on the
hand and that one actually didn't make
the movie interesting so it wasn't that
the shot got replaced it was an actual
different shot that just didn't make the
Final Cut it was just a different shot
wow because you can actually see like he
goes up and then Dives back into the
water and gets thrown off the skin wing
and then he like looks at his hand he's
got some blood there well you can see
that blood in the teaser shot the shot
in the teaser is that a shot where only
the hand is real and everything else is
CG or is that something we're looking at
more of a fully no shot they're both
done exactly the same so in this one the
foreground hand the one that's squeezing
is real the skim Wing is mostly replaced
the water is mostly replaced yeah
because we were looking at the detail of
the water
the actual saddle itself the way it was
going into that thin film style glooping
on to the actual saddle in a very very
realistic way CG
same with those even those bubbles there
yeah wow because we had to we had to
replace the skim Wing underneath because
we had to make that an actual skin Wing
because that was what I was thinking I
was like there's a freaking and creature
underneath all of that and it's too hard
to like match the it's there's a little
bit of both in there right like it's all
mixed where you can use the live action
you use it even if you end up projecting
it back onto geometry um you guys have
done the same thing one other thing we
started using on this was live depth
compositing with CG and live action
together as you watch it one of the
weird things we weren't expecting out of
that is we also get per frame geometry
oh wow so we have an exact geometry for
all the action and for how everything's
moving so we can do projection from the
live action plate back onto the geometry
okay I want to ask a lot more about that
because that's pretty mind-blowing but
let's finish looking at this first here
okay so we're now looking at the Saddle
there and of course you guys have a
digital copy of the saddle so all of the
saddle was replaced well no the pit
under his thumb is from the original
also okay well it's part replaced
because the water height is different on
the two so part of it you replace part
of it you don't and when the water is
coming up on it we have to match our CG
water to it so you project it on you
keep what you can and you put the water
back over the top it's interesting I
mean you get like the hyper detail like
the water splashing on the hand and like
on the little like surface texture of
that woven pad under his thumb but then
you have everything else
that's so intense because water is a is
a complex material in how it behaves you
know big macro scales of this is like
oceans and then you have the tiny thin
film stuff but no solver can do each of
those types of interactions all at the
same time we took all those different
states right the big waves the small
waves the crashing on the shore the
interaction with the boats we taught a
big system how to do that and so it knew
all the different ways to solve water
and how to put it all together and how
it interacts with spray and mist and
like the bulk volume of it we could
simulate it all and run it all as one
big pass and get all those elements for
shots like this so you do one pass for
the whole thing and it gives you all the
different elements the splashes the
bubbles all the interaction bubbles are
a big thing like air bubbles under the
water is that part of the water
simulation or is that a whole different
type of simulation Tech it is part of
the water simulation you see it here
right the interaction of the creature
going into the water and it's depending
on the viscosity of the water and if the
shot starts and his mouth is below the
water and it moves down you're not going
to get any bubbles so you have to make
the whole mouth go above the water come
down in pull the small diffuse Bubbles
and the big bubbles and get all those
interactions you have to do a lot more
thinking about the shots and what
happens before the shot to get the right
bubbles but the bubbles are all part of
the same simulation package yeah because
there's a the one dude who's like
underwater and he like blows out a bunch
of air from his mouth and it's kind of a
close-up it's just this huge like bubble
shot it's in the trailer I just remember
thinking man I've never been excited
about bubbles since I was like five and
here I am again so you have this crazy
water system that can do all these
different things what's an aspect of
water that it still can't do the thing
we had the hardest time with was
raindrops on people because tracking a
raindrop having it hit someone's
shoulder and then do a little Crown
Splash and then drip down and interact
with clothes interact with hair and
things like that other water droplets
and other water droplets so it combines
with other water that's honestly the
thing that we struggled with the most we
figured it out in the end but it was one
of those weird things that we weren't
really accounting for but Jim had a lot
of rain in this movie it wasn't like the
first movie where there were what one
scene with rain he used rain to help
tell emotion so we really wanted to do
all these things interacting together
and like characters you need to be able
to see the hair interact with the water
you see the hands the teeth and that's
what sells the water I feel like an
unsung hero in all this is the hair like
I was like water and the water is
amazing and it's in the name of the
movie but the hair yeah I mean it's like
hair yeah but the hair is like perfectly
photo real and like the hair Moves In
The Water it moves in the air and it
gets wet and it dries out like you guys
are doing some crazy things with the
hair it's very different than the first
movie first movie we did Big cloth
strips and that would account for 20 30
hairs and so that clostrip would move
around but the hairs would all sort of
do this as it's like a texture on a
piece of cloth and in this film every
individual hair is simulated on its own
on the braids the peach fuzz on the
braids is simulated so in the wind they
all move around and you get much better
performance and you get things you
wouldn't expect like lowak he's got that
one braid right that is always hanging
here yeah we're hanging here and Jim
always said that's the whole reason in
Terminator 2 that Eddie had that hair
that always hung down on his face and he
wanted the same feel
well that's a cool fun fact it's very
important that you subscribe so you
don't miss out when our upcoming Avatar
3 content drops right around the corner
like what four three four years from now
subscribe
I want to talk about the motion capture
because that was I think one performance
capture sorry John Lando will call you
and yell at you
promise yes
[Laughter]
sort of system you develop
the way of water Jim's first thing he
said was I want to capture everything
underwater I want to do it in one volume
so that the actors can go underwater and
onto the surface and out of the water
and never miss a beat so one of the guys
at Lei Ryan champney came up with a
system where he basically did a volume
underwater and a volume above water the
two were in sync and it's all one
capture which was it was a trick in
itself yeah I was about to say because
the sort of challenges involved for
capturing underwater versus above water
are completely different not to mention
the whole like visual refraction
differences between underwater and above
water yep exactly like this shot here
right you see the reflection under the
surface and it screws up all your
cameras so they covered the surface in
ping pong balls oh wow which essentially
got rid of all the reflections under the
surface and above the surface and then
you could just tie the two together okay
so let's just clarify that for a quick
second for everybody so motion capture
is tracking an objects especially
already
oh
you know you're in trouble when John
calls you hi John
hi I hear these rumors you're on a talk
show with people are talking about stuff
and calling it motion capture it's
performance capture how does he know I
can't believe that
motion capture Eric is missing one key
letter in front of an e key motion
capture the emotion of an actor that's
why we call it performance capture come
on I'm sorry John sorry John yeah
everybody all right we're dialing
I told you he'd know he always knows I'm
rewinding It Go going back even further
just the old days of tracking a ping
pong ball on his face right so you're
using optical cameras to do something
like that now if you put up a mirror
well that confuses the camera which
thing is the real thing it's the same
reason you can't photo scan things that
are reflected in a mirror so the surface
of the water is a mirror especially if
you're below it and so if you're trying
to do performance capture and a volume
and using optical tracking yeah that's
just gonna screw it all up screws it all
up
foreign so in the first Avatar movie
there was a big water sequence where
Jake Sully jumped off of the waterfall
and went through the river and that was
all done with the process called Thrive
for wet essentially he was just hung
from wires and pretended to be
underwater but that doesn't give you the
same performance that you would get if
you're actually underwater because
there's resistance to your motion well
first I'll correct you in that Jake was
sitting in a office chair with wheels
getting pushed around the performance
capture stage for the first movie
and going like this so it was very
different experience okay
just talking performance capture
underwater you can see it when all the
characters are swimming right you
understand that they're in the water
because the way their arms are moving
the way they move around it feels much
more real whereas if it was dry for wet
you always get that overacting right
like okay pretend you're underwater Oh
everyone I'm underwater y'all yes
exactly
I want that it's Jim would never let
that happen so putting them in the water
they act like they really are yeah
because some of the subtlety that I'm
noticing is just like the way everyone's
legs from like the knees down are always
kind of moving just kind of trying to
tread water a little bit I don't think
that's something that you would think of
doing in a dry for wet scenario where
like oh yeah just just the bottoms of my
life you're just constantly like going
like you're saying it's always overly
exaggerated so I gotta take a moment
here to give a big shout to whatever
actually taking the time to clear clips
and share behind the scenes Clips with
us and breakdowns to support a little
YouTube show like ours and to take the
time to put that out there like it just
it means a lot to us and it's for all of
you to watch so one big Collective thank
you to WETA for that what a big deal
all right Ren cut it out
we cannot let you bring your War here so
you mentioned that there's a new facial
performance capture system for Avatar
too and instead of one camera there's
two cameras now but how does the actual
animation of these faces from that data
how has that changed so in our old
system right it was called a fax based
system and we started that back on
Gollum and it was hundreds and hundreds
of models we would take those models and
we would blend shape and interpolate in
between them right but sometimes in
between two shapes you got something
weird so then you had to go in and model
those fix those shapes and sort of try
to figure out what was supposed to be in
between with our new system it's using
deep learning it's sort of a neural net
of different poses to know how the
different shapes work together so it
figures out the muscle system and how
that should react with the facial itself
so you get a much better interpolation
of what the face should be doing and it
doesn't use any models anymore it's
basically like okay you want this shape
here's the muscles that would fire to
give you that shape yeah wow and then
from there it's literally just
simulating the motion of those muscles
underneath the skin and then the skin is
just like a shrink wrapped thing on top
of it exactly
[Applause]
these shots are insane to me I mean all
of it's insane but like the ones where
you have live action people yeah in the
scene I mean I don't is The Rock real is
the rock fake like you know how much of
this like how
how did you do this
well actually every one of these shots
is a little bit different
so a lot of these shots it's Jack on a
green screen this one is actually a Digi
double I was about to say for a lot of
these shots Jack could very easily
placed in digitally and that helps
seamlessly bring stuff together assuming
the camera's not too close right the the
problem with this one is Jim actually
wanted to shoot it but the camera would
have been 10 feet outside the roof of
this studio we were shooting in so we
couldn't actually get the camera where
it needed to be to get the shot this one
we actually have spider on a fake rock
pulling a seven foot tall guy in a blue
suit he wasn't big enough he was really
skinny um so he didn't have enough
volume so what we ended up keeping was
the Rock and the water at the base of
his feet and some of the stuff dripping
off him is real but he's actually
replaced from the waist down with CG
wait wow really yeah we kept his upper
half and we replaced his lower half with
CG so that we could get the water
interacting with his feet properly so
insane it's like a weird combination for
all of them right like you use what you
need to use and you replace what you
need to replace Jack's arm is replaced
here too so that we can get a better
grip so you have to have Flawless 3D
models and rendering going on to pull
this off yes like well we we had to have
a perfect version of Jack as a CG spider
can you describe what depth compositing
is so Jim uses simulcam and simulcam is
like live action and CG characters in
the same shot um and as he moves the
camera around he can see the CG
characters in the live action camera
that was like kind of the big pioneered
sort of thing from the first avatar yeah
which was how he was able to like film
live action Style on a digital set like
yeah now we just call virtual production
but the downfall on the first film was
if the two overlapped each other the cg1
was always going to be just over the top
um you could never really put them in
there properly so in this one we used
two Basler cameras which are just two
little cameras on the side of our camera
rig and we generate depth using deep
learning and it can distinguish what is
layered on top of one another so that if
Spider goes from behind Scorch to in
front of Courts he shows up correctly
and and even in the water we could use
our depth compositing to see what
characters are layered in the water in
the right depth so in this one you
basically got where the splash was right
and where the wave is coming in so you
could plug that into Loki into the
simulation and you could tell Loki this
is where the waves coming in this is the
timing of the wave and get proper
simulation to match the live-action one
yeah I would say that would give you
like volume and velocity data yeah
cool handy little things to have yeah
how did you guys handle eye lines and
stuff because like for a movie like this
you got all these digital people that
Jack's having to like look at and
they're all like twice as tall as him
yep did you have the tennis ball
um you know when you watch a NFL game
okay and you see that camera whizzing
around the above the cable cam the cable
camera super cool we set up a cable cam
it basically ran from each corner of the
set and it dropped down and it had a
little monitor on it with like slang
space and we could plug in the
performance capture of slang into the
cable cam which you could then position
accurately in 3D space of the actual set
yeah it just did it for us because he he
acted in that same set right so yeah we
just float above his head it just moved
around so when Jack was talking to slang
he would talk to the Monitor and he
would have a proper eye line proper
timing he could interact with it if we
needed him to shake hands with someone
or touch someone right we could have of
Kevin Dorman again in a blue suit and he
could just sort of walk around and look
up see where the cable cam was and just
sort of walk under it and be at the
right time and give him perfect timing
did anyone ever get bonked in the head
by the monitor no that was one of the
biggest worries
because that's a big danger with cable
cans in general yeah the first few times
it got set off everyone sort of stayed
really clear of it but it was it was
very stable and it worked to work to
treat if you're enjoying this video but
you haven't got enough of it well guess
what there's an extended version of this
episode right now on quarterdigital.com
we go into a lot more detail we don't
have to worry about algorithms or
anything like that just it's real talk
here how many years of post did you guys
spend on Avatar 2. official post once we
stopped filming two years how an
unofficial post uh seven years
because if you really go back right like
we finished the first avatar Jim took
some time off figuring out what the next
ones were going to be and then we got
back into working with him on the Lei
stage and really starting to get into it
and then he started giving us test shots
to start working with so we've sort of
been on and off on this for the past
seven or so years if you guys don't win
the Oscar for best VFX there's something
wrong in the world
it's you never know there's some great
movies out there this year so you just
never know what happens and I think the
visual effects in this movie add to the
movie which is really what you want from
it right like it's not a movie about
visual effects like a lot of movies are
it's just a movie and it happens to have
a lot of visual effects they help add to
the movie they just aren't there to just
make explosions or make weird magic
things happen or whatever so what's next
for you guys right like you have this
crazy physics system here and you have
all these crazy pieces of technology
that can drive performance what's next
what's the next egg to crack that's
always sort of an unknown right like
what's gonna be the next challenge I
think we've got water sort of solved but
there there's new elements to the next
film which I can't unfortunately give
away too much but there's new elements
that we're going to have to figure out
new tricky things to make work to sell
the whole film again yeah I mean when
you're talking about all the Ewoks
coming out of the the holes in the
mountains simulating all that's gonna be
crazy
the snakes the dinosaurs we'll have all
those weird dinosaurs that uh have jet
packs on
Eric thank you so much for joining us
it's been great being here it's been a
lot of fun and if you ever have a
question about a shot again just give me
a call I wish I had your number last
year I would have been I would have so
much easier could have saved you an
episode it saved me a lot of people on
the internet yelling how wrong I am
and it's not motion capture it's
performance capture and we're gonna
remember that and we're gonna stick with
that from here on out unless we're just
doing motion capture just basic motion
capture it's not about the acting at all
you guys know so oh not careful